every day we make decisions decisions
that get us from one day to the next
decisions will change our path ever so
slightly then there's the other
decisions I'm getting a real job I'm not
gonna lie you sound crazy
hey I don't want to be some loser
robbing families
[Music]
are you okay
you know I'm robbing you right now no
that's cool are you trying to kill
yourself
mm-hmm can you close the door on your
way out why didn't you just call the
cops and leave I know the protocol is
after almost time
what is your plan here you know you
can't just babysit me forever you say
that like you think I actually have a
plan what are you supposed to eat after
almost OD'ing on painkillers oh my god
I'll eat just stop talking both of you
I'm gonna do it okay and there's nothing
that you can do or say that's gonna stop
me from happening that's not true it's
selfish of you to make me stay
I guess I'm selfish then I think you're
making a mistake I think you could be
happy
[Music]
I look ridiculous
why do you like me
I don't think you want to do this
[Music]
so I must the meaning of all this thing
dezzy
[Music]
you